fonction à la fois ange gardien et
chiens de garde cette fonction ce sera
celle du directeur national de la
protection de la jeunesse
un poste origine leur en demande à
québec de créer son rôle c'est pas un
rôle de boss des dpj
mais un autre pour s'assurer que pour
les enfants
il va avoir une uniformisation et de
meilleures pratiques à travers tout le
québec
quelqu'un à la dpj qui devra rendre des
comptes
alors que les cas de maltraitance
continuent de se multiplier on
souhaitait un protecteur de l'enfance
mais bon ça se rejoint énormément le
mode de nomination peut différer mais
c'est une bonne chose c'est la seule
recommandations de ce rapport
préliminaire mais en soulignant des
constat déplorable comme la
surreprésentation des enfants
autochtones le financement inadéquat la
détresse des parents des jeunes et des
intervenants
il met aussi la table pour des
changements à venir suggérant même une
modification de la loi
on a eu tellement d'exemples où l'enfant
sa voix sa volonté et ses droits parce
que l'enfant a des droits ne sont pas
respectés alors pour tous les exemples
qu'on ne lui faut absolument que qui est
des changements législatifs c'est
surtout ce qui réjouit jesse y gagner et
jessica côté guimond deux adultes qui
ont été des enfants de la dpj
j'ai fait vingt placements et
déplacements trois tentatives de retour
à la maison
iason que vu ce portrait dans tout le
déplacement que j'ai eu
parce qu'on s'intéressait seulement 1 me
comportement en russie que jesse collet
lui aussi trop bien j'étais suivi en
lien avec des motifs de compromission un
sou à négligence abus physiques et
mauvais traitements psychologiques
exposition la violence conjugale
mais aujourd'hui ils ont l'impression
que leur voix la commission ont été
entendus je suis très content d'entendre
que la parole des jeunes doit tête
maintenant au coeur des solutions nounou
priorité c'était vraiment la
participation des jeunes je pense
qu'elle était entendue reste à voir
concrètement comment qu'on veut lui
mettre sur pied et c'est en avril
prochain avec le dépôt du rapport final
qu'on pourra le constater
d'ici là la commission laurent espère
la personne sera nommé à la direction
nationale de la protection de la
jeunesse
d'ailleurs le ministre délégué lionel
carmant a déjà dit qu'il s'agissait
d'une idée très intéressante et qu'il y
donnera suite rapidement et si jacques
andré charbonneau radio canada mon frère